welcome is so lovely to see you all here
today I'm your host Lizzy Daly and I am
thrilled to be bringing you all on an
epic journey to meet some the world's
best scientists wildlife experts and
National Geographic explorers from
around the world live and I mean live
we're going to be chatting to people who
have explored deep into the ocean who
have visited some of the world's most
remote places and someone who's come
face to face with bears as well so this
is a real opportunity for you guys to
get your questions in to our experts
live and also just hear some
behind-the-scenes stories and epic
wildlife tales as well now firstly I'd
like to introduce myself to you so I'm a
biologist and Wildlife TV host from the
UK coming from not so sunny UK right now
but yeah I mean I've been so lucky
myself feel really privileged to explore
across the world documenting wildlife
but my real job is actually as a
scientist so are we I'm using animal
attached tag technology on wildlife to
better understand animal behavior with
the real focus so look at those species
that are coexisting alongside earth
alongside humans and I think it's fair
to say that it's a global conversation
human to wildlife coexistence and I'm
sure it's one that you watching can can
resonate with wherever you are in the
world and it's a topic that we'll be
talking about today with our fantastic
guests speaking of which I am very
excited to welcome today's guest today
we're going to be chatting to dr. Rhea
wind grant now she's a large carnival
ecologist an incredible scientist
inspiring woman she's done so so much
she's a National Geographic Society
fellow she's currently working in
Montana looking at how she can better
wildlife corridors or bear corridors
that's helped conserve bears she's our
main focus on bears she's like the black
bears grizzly bears she's even worked
with African lions in Tanzania and Kenya
just an incredible woman and she's here
with us now hello ray hi there Hey
Lissie how's it going it's so good it's
even better than you're here and I've
just been learning all about what you
want your career looks like as a bear
biologist and I mean I think perhaps an
obvious place to start with is is what
does it like to be face to face with
Bayes as your job you know it's amazing
I have to say I used to be a kid just
sitting around in my living room
watching nature shows on TV and watching
these hosts get face to face with large
carnivores and I wanted to do that when
I was a kid I didn't realize that I was
watching science happen on TV and so I
still feel so fortunate that I landed
this career where I get to do the
science which is very purposeful as you
know just save endangered species from
extinction and also get to have so much
fun handling them tracking them watching
them observing them it's really amazing
I feel like I'm the luckiest person in
the world and I can't wait to tell
people all about what it is in case
anyone else wants to do it for a living
yeah it's such an incredible job that
you have have you been out with bears
today where are you currently oh my
goodness well I have to say I am not
anywhere close to bears right now I'm
actually in an urban space so I am in
Southern California right now at this
moment although I study bears in the
West I study bears in the Wild West in
western United States that is and so I'm
usually high up on top of mountains or
deep in forests
right now I'm actually in a very urban
space and I'm trying to make it look a
little bit more natural but I am not too
far away from bears and as you know
Lizzy a lot of our urban areas in the
world are actually places that are kind
of surrounded by wildlife areas so I'm
close enough to the San Bernardino
Mountains in Southern California which
have a number of large carnivores
unfortunately I won't be seeing any
today but I brought all my knowledge and
a couple of props here to be able to
talk to you guys about it and actually
I'm sitting in front of a pond actually
there's this I don't know if you can see
it kind of whatever bear inside the pond
is the movement
see this pond right here it is full of
bears very favorite food so it is full
of big fish these are koi fish and
actually in my work I get a lot of phone
calls from people who have really
beautiful koi ponds in their backyards
and they'll call me and say there's a
bear eating all of my decorative fish in
my yard and I have to say like well you
can't blame them because that's a so
anyway I am reminded of bears I would
love it if a bear came and snatched a
fish or two from here and affairs are
all around you at all times and in your
mind at all times and I I don't blame
you I mean you have really beaten
face-to-face with lots of different
species in loads of different places I
mean can you tell us about a memorable
encounter or one particular encounter
with a bear that you just absolutely
loved yeah you know that's a great place
to start because I usually get the
question from audiences about you know
have you ever had a close encounter with
a large carnivore I absolutely have
whether it's been Lions in Africa or
bears in North America and the common
theme is that I get myself into a little
bit of trouble with these animals
every time I'm not following the rules
so whenever I kind of let my guard down
and I'm not really on top of my game
that's when something scary happens so I
say that because it's important to be
safe it's important to always respect
these animals if you're dealing with
bears carry bear spray you know carry
some way of protecting yourself the
times that I haven't done it I have
gotten chased by bears I've never been
hurt thank goodness I don't know but one
of the reasons is that I set traps for
them and when I'm setting a bear trap
it's for a purpose of capturing the bear
to check on its health and well-being so
a very short procedure but every so
often I will approach my trap a little
too soon where there's a bear in the
area that just hasn't gotten trapped yet
so it's free-ranging and it's usually
not very happy with me and I have been
chased a couple of times and it's been
really really frightening yeah but in
general especially with black bears
they're not out there to kill people to
hurt people to maul people they're only
aggressive
when they feel threatened and so if you
change a situation so that they can
understand that you're not a threat to
them you're usually fine but fair right
number one yeah absolutely and that's I
think that's a really important note
because often people go out hiking and
you know you're very much in their
habitat so it's really important to just
bear that in mind and it's funny as well
because you you as a scientist as a
biologist I guess you are instinctively
constantly thinking about ABARES
behavior but sometimes you just you
can't predict where an animal may be
coming from right no absolutely not and
also sometimes you can't necessarily
identify the sex of the animal just by
looking so I know it's a female if she
has her cubs with her just from a
distance but if the Cubs they're up a
tree or if they're somewhere else I
might not know she's a female females
are so protective of their cubs they're
more likely to get aggressive with a
person just off the bat and so sometimes
the judgment you make is actually not
actually what is going on and you just
have to be agile adapt and the biggest
thing I can say is give these animals
space I mean humans are not meant to be
face to face with animals I do it in the
name of science and biology I know you
do too but that is really the only
appropriate way to have those
interactions absolutely spot-on so and
no I kind of want to talk very shortly
and shortly about your research and how
you actually go about approaching and
and studying bears but before that I
just kind of you do cover large
carnivores that's kind of your your
title so with your passion for
conservation you know why large
carnivores this bit of a city question
really but because who wouldn't want to
study the big animals of the world you
know I have to say sometimes I feel like
I'm competing with primatologists
because primates are just so fascinating
and you know there's so much like us
that sometimes I'm like oh yeah primary
sensory next I hope so but large
carnivores because they they mean a lot
in terms of the ecosystem so large
carnivores being top predators really
are able to control a lot of trophic
levels right so all the way down to soil
back to you
we see the impacts of large carnivores
so when they're missing from an
ecosystem it can actually have these
terrible cascading effects so the
conservation need is very very strong
and I want to make sure that all of the
world's top predators
you know remain around even the ones in
the water even the Sharks and the you
know killer whales and all of that and
then at the same time large carnivores
have a lot of cultural significance so I
really think it's interesting how many
indigenous groups have revered bears and
lions and carnivores for so so long you
know we have children's stories about
bears and wolves and there's just
there's so a part of human survival and
kind of the human journey and story that
there's this ecological and this
cultural significance and I just can't
get away from and I just think it's
fantastic so I'm hooked I'm hooked
forever and I also think there's a lot
of ways that lots of people out there
maybe some of the people who are tuning
in now can explore being a part of the
conservation of large carnivores so we
need people who are scientists and
biologists but we also need educators
and artists and filmmakers and
photographers and you know advocates and
all cut writers you know all kinds of
people will play a role in making sure
that we continue to have these animals
absolutely yeah and fascinating that you
do you kind of cover a breadth of
studies and understanding of these
animals and you'll totally spot on
everyone's interconnected with nature
right in some capacity but I mean you've
got to say you really have an epic job
so though I want to know as a pepper oil
it is what how do you go about studying
bears what do you do let's say it's a
it's a day in the life of you you're out
in the field and you're about to go and
find a bear what do you do yeah
absolutely so the first thing I have to
do is usually set up some kind of camera
trap so that is like the first thing I
want to do because I need to make sure
that there are actually bears in this
area that I'm studying I don't want to
waste my time I don't have a lot of so I
brought a camera trap for you guys to
see maybe some of you guys are familiar
they can be fancy and high-tech they can
be really kind of simple and low-tech
this is the one that I use so this is my
camera trap
a number of them it's kind of camouflage
which i think is funny because the bears
don't care at all and it actually makes
it harder for me to find so I am going
to get up take a little trip with me
gonna show you how I attach it to a tree
so oh this is something was so great
here is my camera we're gonna just do
the teeny tiny tree behind me cuz again
I'm just an odd in the wild I'm in this
urban space so usually we'd have a
thicker nicer tree but this one right
here and I just have to get my light
adjusted so that you can actually see me
hold on there we go beautiful thing it's
too beautiful oh the camera trap is
really easy what we're gonna do is we
just open it up on the side here yep and
you can see it uses a lot of batteries
they are rechargeable batteries so don't
worry about that well yeah there are
different settings here again these are
all turned off but all you do is you
kind of turn it on flip it to on and
close it back up and you can see this
red button that just lit up right here
that means that it on and it's ready so
a camera trap is a motion sensor so it
means whenever something goes by it it
actually takes an image it takes a
snapshot of whatever it goes by so if
it's me walking around not remembering
where I set my camera then it'll get a
lot of shots of me but hopefully it's
getting pictures of bears mountain lions
you know bobcats whatever is in the area
so oh go ahead lizzy the position you
you placed on the tree is really
important right especially for your
subject those are important
yeah absolutely so I'm gonna position it
on this tree and again just guys to kind
of get a sense of what it's like I loop
it through here and then tighten it up
so it is we are getting all the action I
mean I wanted to know how to be a bear
biologist though we're literally seeing
it right here literally seeing kind of
the dirty work hole on this camera trap
and I did a really sloppy job again
because it's kind of hard to do this on
camera
but you can see it now and it's
positioned another thing you want to do
is just kind of figure out what the
angle is right so it has a pretty big
field of view but sometimes I'll take
like a little stick or a branch and you
know stick it in right here so the
angles down a little bit more stick it
in down here to make sure it angles up a
little bit more and basically make sure
that it's catching exactly what I want
it to catch so an area that a bear might
walk by you get this how many bees we
pop up you know in one ecosystem I might
have as many as 10 or 15 camera traps in
different spaces and that's to make sure
that we're covering a wide area right
because bears are wide-ranging they're
not just using one tiny space they can
travel many many many miles many many
kilometers in a single day and they are
also territorial right so bears are not
in prides like lions or packs like
wolves you're gonna find one bear at a
time usually so in order to make sure
that they're there you have to set as
many of these as possible
so I might have 10 or 15 which means I
spend a lot of time hiking around the
forest actually trying to check these
camera traps and best-case scenario I'll
get a couple of camera traps that picked
up images of bears and that tells me
finally I'm in the right spot bears
actually live here and I can get to work
setting some traps to get to know them
more another thing a camera trap might
pick up is different types of prey for
bears right so like small deer or other
small mammals and you know sometimes a
few surprises like like they can pick up
poachers illegal hunters you know those
kinds of things that give us really good
information for conservation as well so
this is a really great tool I always
want to emphasize the camera trap it's
so basic I feel like probably there's
viewers here who say oh yeah I have
those in my garage so that I can see
what's going on outside of my house
there are a great non-invasive way to
study animals because we don't always
want to be hands on to these animals we
really want to give them their space in
the name of science and this is the best
tool for it absolutely and have you ever
captured any unusual behaviors or some
exciting behaviors from bears on these
cameras before
my favorite thing the capture our when I
do find a mother with Cubs because it's
a great way to kind of interact with
that family without actually scaring
them away or making them habituated to
humans and the Cubs are so precious and
cute I mean just seeing their little you
know Lizzie you study behavior of
animals so just seeing the way that they
behave and understanding the more is
really amazing
I've also been able to find mountain
lions in places where I did not know
there were mountain lions well one time
some really amazing human I'm sorry
black bear mountain lion interactions
where a mountain lion had a kill ate
some of it and then stashed it away
a black bear came down from the slopes
of the mountain and stole the kill of
the mountain lion and they had a bit of
a faceoff together it was absolutely
incredible
it's amazing footage and fortunately it
wasn't video footage it was just
pictures but it really helped us
understand that wow these interactions
are happening here and perhaps that
means there actually isn't enough prey
to go around that they're fighting over
so it's helping us understand
conservation needs as well the
environment you know the ecology of the
area everything gosh with us with a
simple camera out of interest do you
ever get any curious bears coming over
because they must be able to smell a
difference between say like a tree or
substrate to a camera yeah you know not
to the camera thank goodness but I
sometimes put some type of what we call
a scent rag just in the area of the
camera and that's to attract the bear
there so it's not good to bait bears you
know I'm not gonna put food out or
anything unnatural like that but a Sun
rag is quite literally a rag that you
might use in your home to you know to
clean something so clean rag and you
might have put some you know vanilla
extract or like a raspberry scent on it
and you just toss it up into the tree so
just toss it up into the top of the
trees for the winds to carry this scent
a curious bear that's nearby will come
lumbering around and say hey what's that
and luckily they won't go towards the
camera to destroy it because they
absolutely could destroy it but they'll
just so I am I am very careful yeah I'm
sure you have to be right I think now
habitat but okay let's say you've
established you
a grizzly bear is now with this camera
trap what do you do then if there's a
particular individual you want to learn
more about what's the next step yeah so
this is the fun part so let's go back
I'm gonna walk you away from my camera
trap tree so come with me and the
awesome next part is I get to attach a
collar to the animal so I brought a bit
a collar here this is not a color that I
use for grizzly bears it's a little bit
small but it is a large mammal collar
and basically it is almost like a dog
collar so just think of it it is very
very lightweight it does not harm the
animal they do not get attached until
the animal is tranquilized so what I'm
not showing you on screen is a
tranquilizer gun it just doesn't
translate very well but a tranquilizer
gun just has little darts in it the
darts have a medicine that puts the
animal to sleep for 30 minutes to an
hour so that we're not stressing it out
and so i will tranquilize the bear put
it to sleep and then once it's asleep I
do a little health check almost like the
bear is getting like a vet veterinarian
checkup
so it's heart rate it's breathing rate I
comb through its fur to look for
parasites just to make sure it doesn't
have you know too many and then I put
this collar on there's this device in
the collar it looks big but again it's
very very lightweight it's a GPS device
so GPS device like what you might have
in your smartphone and this device sends
a signal to a satellite in outer space
and that satellite sends a signal back
to my computer here wherever I am right
now it's California and then that signal
tells me exactly where on the landscape
that bear is in terms of latitude and
longitude every three hours so I will
demonstrate on myself about this oh here
we go let's pretend that I am the lucky
bear light is able to track my movements
and tell exactly where I am now a lot of
people may ask you know why is this
important
yeah so why is it important to know
exactly where a bear is at all times
well
helps us understand their primary
habitat right so the place that a bear
spends most of its time is its best
habitat and that means those are the
parts of the forest that we need to
protect for the bear some people think
that if you have a forest and bears
gonna use every square inch of the
forest it's not necessarily true and
Lizzie you work at the intersection of
humans and animals and you understand
that a lot of the places animals like to
go are a lot of the places that people
like to go but if we're actually able to
track the movements of these animals we
can be able to figure out how we can
keep humans and animals apart safely
absolutely and okay so I mean that's
quite a pretty incredible experience
that you're able to do that and I ever
seen pictures as well I think maybe some
people will just be curious to know
let's say you've tranquilized or you're
focusing on a mother and you have
there's Cubs there I've seen that you've
put Cubs inside the jacket so what why
do you do that my favorite thing to talk
about so some of my social media or if
you see any videos of the work that I do
you might notice that yes what you're
saying there are some pictures of me
holding Cubs right in their knuckling
them in my jacket yeah it's something
that is a part of the scientific process
so again I'm not saying that anyone
should do this themselves please don't
leave it to experts but when a female
bear has a GPS collar on her that allows
us to find where she's hibernating so
where she's made her den in the
wintertime and all female Bears give
birth in the winter so we actually have
this joke in the ecology community that
every black bear that's ever been born
ever in North America was born in
January and it's actually true so it's
pretty amazing one of the things that we
do is count the Cubs it sounds so simple
but it's a really important part of the
ethological process and the research
study is to just count how many Cubs
were born and then to count again how
many Cubs are emerging from the den in
the spring that tells us about their
survival rate which is super important
so people like me get to go in to these
bear dens again we we give a dart a
tranquilizer guard to the mothers and
she doesn't freak
or stress out and we give her her own
little health checkup and then we do the
same for the Cubs because they're so
little they might be six or eight weeks
old sometimes 12 weeks old they're too
young to actually thermoregulate which
means maintain their own body
temperature so it's actually our job to
hold them in our jackets and give them
our own body heat while we're doing
their checkup so again it is not
something we do for fun although it is a
tremendous life experience but we're
actually making sure that we're keeping
them safe and healthy until we put them
back with their mother and she can keep
them warm yes absolutely I've had the
joy of meeting a young brown bear cub
and it was just full of beans but it was
just such an incredible experience to
you know to witness an animal like that
right in front of you how incredible and
and what a brilliant job and you've
talked about changing landscapes or at
least trying to identify safe areas for
bears so I think it's fair to say
globally this is we're having more human
dominated landscapes so from what you
found in your research I mean what does
this mean in terms of behavior what are
some of the impacts of these changes oh
absolutely I mean I could go on and on
about it so I'll try to be very concise
but a species like a black bear or a
grizzly bear brown bear
they are so driven by hunger they are
just so I mean they're kind of like me
they're just hungry and they're always
in search of food and so because of that
because there's more people that are
closer to their habitats they have
become very very attracted to human food
you know in my science writing I'll call
it anthropogenic resources but it
basically means human food whether it's
what's in your garbage can you know your
trash whether it's what's on your grill
when you're having a barbecue with your
friends maybe it might be your koi pond
in your backyard or your dog food that
you leave up your dog in the backyard
they are just really really hungry
because they have to hibernate so they
have to their job is to get really fat
at some point every year and human food
is a great way to get really fat instead
of eating nuts and berries in the forest
they just have to go an extra couple
miles to raid a dumpster so I'm
thing that it's actually a part of their
instincts so sometimes we as people get
very frustrated with them but we have to
understand this is their instinct
driving their hunger just like our
hunger drives us to and so as we have
more and more people in places and more
and more bears because the conservation
of bears is going pretty well we're
finding more and more places where there
might be conflicts it's really up to
people to be responsible with their
resources with their food to make sure
we're not attracting these animals I
mean yeah you kind of answered my next
question which is kind of what do you
hope will be the outcomes of your
research but I guess it's twofold right
because you're actually conducting the
science that proves that you're finding
bears in these areas and this conflict
is is coming up I don't like you using
the word conflict I say in inverted
commas just because I it's a quite a
negative connotation but we're seeing it
more and more right coexisting of humans
and Wildlife is such a such a big thing
but in terms of like the broader wider
audience so your research can have so
it's so valuable to so many and there's
so widespread so what would you say your
your role as a scientist as a biologist
and is on the on the wider scale oh I
love talking about that because that's a
really good man but essentially what I'm
doing is I'm using different methods to
understand the ecology and behavior of
bears in order to make wider
recommendations for carnivore
conservation globally so the way that I
track bears and the way that I
understand their movements and their
habitat selection helps me make
recommendations for tiger conservation
or wolf conservation or you know a shark
conservation so I'm really using bears
as a model for larger carnivores
globally and what's great is that the
Bears that I study are actually
increasing in population size so we're
having more and more every year instead
of fewer and fewer every year so
hopefully my recommendations will be
useful once we hit that inflection point
with tigers and lions and cheetahs and
once we get them to start rebounding
it's a different type of conservation
process and we'll be ready for it
because of the
me and my colleagues fantastic
absolutely and we talked about that as
an issue you but what are some of the
the other threats to bears and see I
guess different bear species right
because as I said they're widespread
across the planet so they must face
different pressures
oh absolutely so I study bears in North
America but we have bears in South
America we have them in Europe or you
are Lizzy we've got them in Asia and
continental Asia and then Southeast
Asian islands we do not have bears in
Australia or Africa although there is a
prehistoric one on the African continent
yes there is no actually I study mostly
black bears which are the only species
of bears that are not endangered so
again the only one that is in really
really good shape I also study grizzly
bears which are still on the endangered
species list in the United States but
are actually doing pretty well we have
more and more each year there's even a
debate about whether they should be
removed from the endangered species list
but we know us know about what's going
on with polar bears with climate change
warming their environments and
decreasing the amount of sea ice
they are definitely under threat because
their main way of hunting prey is
becoming less and less avail available
to them and then the other species of
bears across the world are also
endangered mostly because of habitat
destruction so you know in the United
States I'm finding that I'm losing a lot
of my bears because they're crossing a
busy highway and getting hit by cars but
in other parts of the world they're just
losing habitat space forests are being
cut down
you know the climate is changing and we
really need to band together as a
conservation community no matter what we
do to make sure that they can remain
protected absolutely yeah that's yeah
well put sometimes it's hard to kind of
put it into into a small digestible bit
of information right because there's
many issues and many threats going on it
can be in a bit daunting sometimes and
for those who perhaps aren't really
integrated in that conservation
community if someone sat at home for
example you know they've never even seen
a bear in the world how can they try and
conserve bears and do their bit as well
absolutely there's so many ways again I
am a carnivore ecologist now but I
started off as a kid watching TV and I
started subscribing to National
Geographic magazines kid so I could
learn much more about the greater world
so there's always ways that you can you
know donate your money there always you
can donate your time if you're not able
to donate money to volunteer for
conservation groups the thing that I
tell people more than anything is to use
their voting power there's always things
on the ballot whether it's a local
election or a national election there's
always something to vote for or against
that impacts the environment and voting
is a very very powerful tool if anyone
is tuning in in the United States you
know that environmental legislation is
always a part of the conversation so I
always implore everyone no matter where
you are in the world if it is safe for
you to vote please please use your
voting power to help save all these wild
animals and wild places ultimately it's
those policies isn't it the supports the
work of you and and the bear biologists
oh yeah absolutely and and I guess a bit
of a killer question sorry to ask it but
if they're a species of bear that you're
just like dying to work on or one that
you'd you still really keen to to learn
more about I mean you must know
everything there is to know about bears
I'm sure okay well I like to think so
but there's always more to learn because
all right systems are always changing
and so you know Lizzie you know this the
way that these animals are react to
changes in the ecosystem can be
unpredictable so there's always more
science to learn I have to say my
twitter account gets pinged a lot of the
time by folks in Japan because there is
a species of bear called the Hokkaido
bear high in the mountains in one of the
northern islands of Japan that is under
pretty serious threat and doesn't get a
lot of national attention so people are
really thinking about Hokkaido bears and
so I get people asking me hey will you
come out to Japan will you help us with
our bear conservation work and I've been
to Japan I've only been as a tourist and
I absolutely loved it so I really feel
like I need to get there and get into
that work so that is my dream dream
dream that's what's your space that's
the next mission that's awesome
so at the beginning I know
people to send in their questions should
we get to some of them because I can see
some brilliant ones flying in here and
we've got I guess one want to start with
which I think it's quite a common
question is you know differentiating
bears so could you just run through some
of the differences between grizzly bears
black bears and brown bears okay yeah no
problem so this is North Americans
Pacific we have brown bears in both
North America and in Europe which is
pretty cool but black bears are the
smaller North American bear species and
so they are small or usually sometimes
in the western United States are
actually very very large and they're a
bit more omnivorous and grizzly bears or
brown bears are but they're smaller they
have pointy rears they have a longer
kind of snout sometimes people mistake
them for dogs if they're like small
enough whereas Risley bears and it's
important for me to say that a grizzly
bear is a subspecies of a brown bear so
all grizzly bears are brown bears not
all brown bears are gross aggressive
that makes like oh it's there's part of
the same species black bears and grizzly
bears are different species and Krishna
bears are bigger brown bears are bigger
they are larger in fact they can be
incredibly large like up to you know a
thousand pounds sometimes more depending
on the season and they're large they're
more aggressive they are brown in color
almost always and they have curvier
years and more of a compacted snout so
they kind of have a flatter face and
then you know of course bigger paws and
bigger proper ends and a little bit of a
different cloth structure so there you
go you're looking for characteristics to
tell the difference is it I think it's a
common question what you must get asked
like quite a lot is the different you
know and especially out here in the
western United States because many of
the black bears here out west are
actually brown in color right well I
spend a lot of time explaining to people
no you did not see a grizzly bear in
your backyard it was a brown colored
black bear well maybe we can get
confusing to people so I always tell
them it's kind of like human beings
yeah all one species were almost APNs
there's only one species of human but we
have different hair color even have
different skin color and that can be the
case with black bears they're all one
species but black bears can be black
they can be brown the community gray
they can be blond and there's even a
subspecies of black bear in Canada that
is completely white Wow
there we are so yeah mixed up with our
polar bears I've also heard of a growler
bear am I right in saying there's
potentially growler bears somewhere up
in Alaska you know this is no longer a
scientific mystery but for a while it
was it means it's a hybrid between a
grizzly bear and a polar bear and for a
while scientists didn't really think it
was possible because polar bears are on
the ice and grizzly bears are on the
land the tundra but it looks like as the
climate has changed and polar bears have
come more inland for their hunting
they've interacted with grizzly bears
and hybridized a bit to make a growler
bear again I've never seen one I believe
only one or two have ever been captured
on camera so it's kind of still like
this new emerging completely fascinating
hybrid species yeah very fascinating
indeed grown-up bears I mean I only
heard of that this year so so much to
bed we have another gritty great
question here what do bears eat from
region to region and does it change
significantly with species in geographic
area or in winter so it covers quite a
lot there but yeah let's talk about diet
I don't think the person who wrote in
this question kind of already knows the
answer because the answer is yes of
course it changes by region so if I take
black bears as an example in the United
States we have black bears that live in
desert systems we have them that live
high and Aspen our Alpine mountain
systems we even have black bears in the
eastern United States that live on the
coast at the beach you know we have
black bears in Florida and Everglades
which is like a tropical ecosystem and
then of course they are in Canada and
Alaska and at higher higher latitudes
and so they eat different things in
different places there are bears that
are nowhere near freshwater fish no or
near rivers or lakes or students that
have fish and so they never eat fish
their entire
lives whereas we have bears that live in
places that have a heavy fish diet
almost all the time but the great thing
about black and brown bears is that they
are generalists so they will eat almost
anything edible whether it's berries
nuts seeds honey
insects eggs small mammals fish the
Bears that I study in the West will hunt
and take down wild horses Wow incredible
we know that grizzly bears and spaces
like Montana will take down bison so
they can be very aggressive predators or
they can be very very passive scavengers
certainly they're eating ramps up when
they're getting ready to hibernate and
then when they hibernate they don't eat
anything at all for many many many
months their bodies shut down their
metabolism slowed to a crawl their
breathing rates slow down their heart
rate slow down and they actually even
recycle their own urine and waste within
their body and they can go you know
almost six months without eating a thing
which is why they're so hungry the rest
of the year right and we often in
science maybe just brush over that fact
I mean how incredible is hibernation
it's decidable oh it's absolutely it's
amazing and sometimes there's a debate
in the scientific community about
whether bears are true hibernators or
not I am happy to debate anyone on this
I am on the side of science that
believes they are true hibernators
because of the metabolism shut down well
but it has been noticed that some mares
might have their eyes open a little bit
or they might you know adjust their
bodies and move around or lick some snow
to get a little bit of water but in
general the principal is that because
their metabolism is so much slower than
normal that they're interesting I didn't
know that either that's fascinating yeah
brilliant and a really interesting
questions come in do you try do you try
to fix their teeth if they have problems
now I've done some health checks on a
brown bear lovely female brown bear in
Romania before and we check gums and we
did have a look at teeth and I'll see
phone things but do you fix them
you know I'm not that person has ever
asked me that before the answer is no
and I hope it doesn't disappoint anyone
but as someone who's not a veterinarian
my job is to check on the health of
health of a bear and if there's some
kind of emergency it's possible that I
might intervene in an emergency and
bring the animal to a wildlife
veterinarian but otherwise their health
is more of a data point so if I'm
checking the teeth of a bear which I
also always do if its teeth are in great
shape then I write that down as data you
know high-quality teeth if their teeth
are not looking so great that's also in
some data some information that tells me
either about the age of the bear like oh
it's teeth aren't great so it must be
old or about the health of the ecosystem
it's teeth aren't great there must be
something off in the ecosystem that is
making this animal unhealthy then my
focus goes to the ecosystem just try to
figure out how we can make it a better
healthier space but not necessarily to
the bear but again that there have been
some times that I've encountered an
emergency with bears in which I've had
to take the animal to a veterinarian in
order to get its health fixed there we
are yes and no but not really but you
know it's a it's a good measure yeah and
it kind of links or the next question
which is how do you age well they've
asked how do you eight twelve animals
but I guess how do you age a bear yeah
teeth are a really great indication but
also size I mean we understand that if
it's teeny tiny and you know kind of has
that young fur and young teeth we know
that it's a juvenile and if it is big
and burly with you know scars and
scratch marks and weathered hair and and
we know it's a bit older but it's a lot
of estimating and guessing so we will
also measure the cranium we'll measure
the head size we will look at teeth and
health condition and just compare it
against other bears that we know about
and be able to age it that way so it's a
lot of educated guesses the best thing
that we can do is again go into those
dens when they're hibernating and find
the Cubs when we're able to identify
Cubs we can track them through their
whole life and then we always know their
exact
and that can be very very useful
long-term data hey so useful absolutely
and another really good question but
yeah one that I am totally passionate
about is how intelligent or bear is
compared to other animals I mean by
bears they're incredible they're amazing
I think they're so smart and it's very
obvious again they're they have big
bodies which means they have pretty big
brains for the animal community so you
can kind of understand but also you know
a lot of us have pet dogs I have a pet
dog I have a teeny tiny little one
doesn't really look like a bear but if
you have a sense that dogs are fairly
smart bears and dogs have a common
ancestor you know so back in the
evolutionary tree they actually came
from a common ancestor so in that way
they often have like similar types of
behavior so certainly you can you know I
don't recommend this but we've seen
examples to people training a bear right
so we've seen bears you know there used
to be a time when bears are in the
circus and things like that things that
are now considered very inhumane but it
was because you can train these animals
because they're smart enough to
understand also you know they are smart
enough to know when there's danger and
they'll back off or when they actually
have the upper hand because they're
bigger and stronger and they can be
aggressive I find them quite quite smart
animals me too absolutely but I mean one
thing I always love is being in the
habitat of a bear and and kind of never
seeing one and never knowing that there
could be a black bear or brown bear you
know not far from you but you wouldn't
know about it because that bears already
clocked you and is already left they're
just incredible absolutely and they have
an amazing sense of smell so these bears
that I study can smell from over a mile
away so I can smell something maybe
that's cooking in the kitchen but not
next door necessarily but these bears
hat can smell from over a mile away
which means they can smell us they can
smell our shampoo and our perfume in our
dogs or whatever it is so more than
likely if a bear if we're seeing a bear
it's choosing to allow us to see it and
like you're saying Lizzy a lot of them
just get out of the way way before we
even know they're there yes absolutely
um a few more questions and then
I've got a complex is flown by it's gone
through it so quickly what is the most
endangered speak their species and you
spoken I'll see about the there bear in
Japan but some in terms of all of the
bears what what would you say is the one
facing the biggest threats well you know
there's actually a couple so I'm going
to argue that polar bears are facing
some of the biggest threats because
we're seeing how rapid their habitat is
changing and it's changing too rapidly
for them to properly adapt to it so
there's a lot of urgency you to work on
saving the habitats of our polar bears
also son bears which are mainly in
Indonesia Indonesia is facing a lot of
huge habitat threats for all of the
wildlife species and son bears are in a
lot of trouble because those rainforests
being cut down are depleting their
habitat and food sources so those are
the ones that I am most concerned about
right now so if you have any way to
donate or volunteer your time to make
some progress for polar bears or the
little bitty cute son bears in Indonesia
that's what I recommend fantastic
and that legs nicely into the next
question and the last question of today
are their conservation efforts we can
take and in our own areas to help
ecology stay in balance what question oh
absolutely absolutely so no matter where
you are there's some type of nature
that's accessible I'm someone who grew
up in big cities I'm from San Francisco
California I didn't go on my first hike
until I was 20 years old I didn't see my
first wild animal until I was in my 20s
so I still considered myself someone who
was a part of conservation as a kid
growing up despite not being out in the
wild and doing that science work so
again gaining awareness watching
programs like these that we're doing on
YouTube with Nat Geo is a great way to
do it
you know if you're old enough and
eligible to vote you know voting in
favor of the environment is something
that you can do from your space but also
just being aware of your consumption so
you know I mentioned son bears in
Indonesia that part of the world has so
many amazing natural resources that
people like us and
in parts of the United States or in
Europe are participating in the
destruction of those habitats just by
our consumer practices so what I mean is
if you think about the things that are
in our food if there's any palm oil and
your favorite snacks palm oil strongly
comes from the tropics where primary
habitat is being destroyed in order to
plant oil palm plantations which impacts
orangutans and bears tons of primates I
mean whole ecosystems so looking at our
consumption and where it comes from is a
really great way to be you know in
whatever space you are even in urban
space and be proactive in conservation
such as sounds racing the supply chains
of what you buy where you wear what you
eat you know how you drive all of that
is really helpful it is helpful and
thinking like a community in that way
and you know not just thinking all the
scientists that study wildlife and so
you know they're really making great
efforts we are all consumers on this
planet and we're all trying to do what
we can to protect the future of you know
our children and future generations to
come
it's been absolutely a joy to chat to
you Ray is there anything else to kind
of finish on a final message that you'd
like to share with everyone here I just
want everyone to understand that you
know careers like ours like mine like
yours Lucy are available to anyone if I
can be you know a girl from an urban
space in a big city who watched TV and
got inspired any single person on this
planet can do it you know you can go
through university systems to get your
science degrees and become active in
science but there are other pathways
just getting a job at a zoo at a
conservation organization working your
way up is a great way to participate in
science in conservation as well and we
need more thinkers more creative
solutions you know more people who care
to join us so that our work can be even
stronger and thank you cuz this has been
awesome for me you know because improve
it I'm not in the field but this is the
next best thing and I'm so grateful
talking about what you love and sharing
that with everyone watching today I'm
sure well I've absolutely loved it and
I'm sure everyone watching
has to so yeah a massive thank you to
you I'm sure you'll continue to spire
inspire many many others as well as
myself and we'll definitely all be
following your next moves and to Japan I
think well and thank you all for tuning
in to this live here we'll be back again
with more fantastic inspiring speakers
and scientists from all over the world
and thanks all for your questions today
and we'll see you here very soon on the
nat geo youtube channel